i as a historian know there is very
little we can say about the next
100 years let alone 10 000 years for
sure on the other hand we can say a lot
about the last ten thousand years and
actually it's quite stunning how much
more we know now than we did a hundred
years ago because of the information the
memory technologies that we're inventing
now to mine material evidence for
information that we never would have
thought possible including you know dna
forensic analysis
so i want to focus tonight on what we
can learn about the future by looking at
the past
so i want to say that if you
if you're really interested in the next
ten thousand years you have no better
evidence to look to than the past ten
thousand years and that's what i want to
talk about tonight
now the story actually begins a lot
earlier than the long now it begins in
the long ago this is actually uh
this is dates from about 40 000 years
ago we think and i'll talk a little bit
more about it but i think that memory
technologies and in fact the human
species really took a real pivotal turn
that moment sort of in the garden of
eden or at least it was a garden of eden
moment when we realized that we're going
to die
as far as we know there is no other
species that understands that they are
going to die not just that their own
partners or something dies their
children dies but that we anticipate
that we're going to die we know that and
i think that it changes everything for
the way humans think about time and i
want to talk a little bit more about
that but this is early evidence from
long ago about 40 000 years ago that
human beings from the very beginnings
became obsessed with cheating death in
fact
and i look at this technology of paint
on cave walls as the earliest concrete
evidence of cheating death by in fact
extrapolating the contents of our mental
life our imagination our you know our
sort of spiritual life and putting it in
a safe place actually we're outsourcing
it to durable physical objects
and you can see it's very familiar we
don't know what these people are telling
us but we know that they're human and we
know that because they actually signed
their own piece of art i think of this
as the earliest kind of um it's a
paleolithic selfie in a way
you know what's so interesting is that
as a species we are not the strongest we
are not the fastest and we are not even
the brainiest i hate to say it but we
actually don't have the biggest brains
and we certainly don't live the longest
the one thing that we have is this
amazing thing that we have collectively
created which is our collective memory a
kind of collective brain which is a
thing that we keep alive over
generations which makes us able to
accumulate knowledge over time and
actually we are now at this juncture on
the planet when we are not only the
dominant species on the planet but
through our collective memory and
collective brain we are dangerously
dominant over the planet that's another
reason why i think this is a really
critical time for us
you know the sense that we have the
certainty that we are separate from
other people that with their we're going
to die and this collective memory that
we have have endowed us with a couple of
unique qualities from other species
we have a certain temporal depth
perception which is very deep very deep
into the future and very deep into the
past
and through this temporal depth
perception we actually can engage in
mental time travel we can deduce what
happened in the past and we can project
that into the future we can we can
engage in conjectural thinking
and through language in fact we can
engage in what i think of as
synchronized mental time travel
no better example is um that crew that
18 or 20 years ago started to put
together the new horizons mission to
pluto and that team and people cycled in
and out of that team at the jpl that
team was engaged in mental time travel
synchronized first astounding period of
time and how they ended up actually
hitting their target
after that especially after the
appropriations scares they received
along the way from our friends in
congress it's really a testimony to how
collective action and collective memory
really is a very powerful thing
[Music]
you